a 14 year old girl still not fully
developed who demands to have her
breasts cut off
a 15 year old boy who wants to have his
penis removed a 10 year old taking drugs
to interfere with hormones that make
puberty possible
this is what joe biden promoted today
to parents of transgender children
affirming your child's identity one of
the most powerful things you can do to
keep them safe and healthy
any transgender american who's
struggling please know you're not alone
to parents and children alike please ask
for help
and know this
you're so brave you belong
and we have your back
now the left loves to pervert language
to promote its twisted agenda so they
brand this parental rights bill in
florida the don't say gay legislation of
course that's not in the bill they refer
to increased pain at the pump as putin's
gas hikes
and now instead of a sex change
operation it's gender affirming care
well today biden made it clear that this
is a hill that his party is willing to
die on encouraging transgenderism among
the youngest americans in fighting
anyone who gets in his way
this is the issue democrats obsess over
wow they're not so concerned are they
with restoring the economy or countering
a rising china or fighting the cartels
importing fentanyl
his number one priority seems to be
mainstreaming transgenderism among our
kids in the workplace in our military
everywhere
to everyone celebrating transgender day
of visibility
i want you to know that your president
sees you the onslaught of
anti-transgender state laws attacking
you and your families is simply wrong
we're committed to advancing transgender
equality in the classroom on the playing
field at work in our military in our
housing and healthcare systems
everywhere simply everywhere
simply everywhere well despite public
opinion polls showing overwhelming
support for florida's new law
biden and the groups allied with the
democrats are obsessed with this issue
now two such organizations filed a
federal lawsuit today against the
parental rights bill claiming that the
law not only stigmatizes and silences
those vulnerable students exacerbating
risk to their welfare but also threatens
school officials who foster a safe and
inclusive environment
these are frivolous claims
students aren't barred from saying
anything in this legislation and
teachers aren't prevented from keeping
anyone safe we want everyone safe
meanwhile disney continues to dig itself
in a giant mouse hole on this issue by
advocating for sexual lesson plans for
five to seven-year-olds
so a boycott disney movement has begun
apparently across america
and now governor desantis is considering
eliminating the special status that
disney receives from the state
there are certain
entities that have exerted a lot of of
influence through through corporate
means
to generate special privileges in the
law
i don't think we should have special
privileges in law at all they've got so
far over their skis on this on this
parental rights stuff because i think
they're used to having their way and
they're not used to having people that
will stand in their way and say actually
the state of florida is going to be
governed by the best interests of the
people in florida you know we're
certainly not going to bend a knee to
woke executives in california
now disney is walking down a very
dangerous trail here
arguably the most important thing they
and other media companies own right now
is their intellectual property meaning
mickey mouse the old film catalogs etc
well trademark and copyrights are
established by congress their length how
long they can be exercised well congress
can always change them
and if it does disney could lose its
exclusive rights to its iconic
characters meaning the image of mickey
mouse could be declared part of the
public domain usable by anyone
now we know that disney knows how
important these trademark and copyright
issues are because the company spends
millions to safeguard them
so every time disney's copyright is set
to retire expire it unleashes an army of
lobbyists and spends millions to get it
extended
so with walt disney long gone and nearly
a hundred years since the mouse first
appeared
why on earth should these works be
walled off from public use it's madness
but not as mad as what disney's former
ceo said today about the florida bill
to me it wasn't politics it was what is
right and what is wrong and that just
seemed wrong it seemed potentially
harmful to kids when you're dealing with
right and wrong or when you're dealing
with something that does have a profound
impact on your business then i just
think you have you'd have to do what is
right and not worry about the potential
backlash to it well the backlash may end
up crippling the business
when americans see the actual language
of the new florida law it wins support
by more than a two to one margin
now among independents is 58 to 26
supporting and my favorite even among
democrats it's 55 supporting the law 29
against
so has iger left his mansion lately to
speak to real people or is this really
where disney wants to take its brand
from being a company known for its
wholesome entertainment to one seeking
to redefine what children consider
normal
against what parents might believe
listen closely to the disney production
coordinator all this content's going for
to kids who don't know any of this and
even if they're in a household like
keith uh that have uh supportive parents
they're still getting all of this
information from media of what is normal
and we just
it's a there's a lot of power to that
and it just needs to be acknowledged
but disney is going to find out very
quickly that the power is with the
parents who pay the taxes that fund the
schools and the power is with the
parents who decide what streaming
service to subscribe their families to
and the power is with the parents who
decide where to go on vacation
and this year it may not be to a disney
theme park
as for the democrats did they not see
what happened to terry mcauliffe in
virginia where schools were the flash
point for so many voters including moms
so if they think that aligning with a
tiny radical element and against parents
is a smart politics here
then they're even more out of touch with
america than we thought
the winds of change that hit washington
will for feel more like a cat 5
hurricane at this rate and that's the
angle hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else